[Music]
Taron did you understand what you
started and where it is now and to be
here at the Golden Globes at this moment
[Music]
why is it important for you to walk this
carpet today what's wrong you know I
thought that I would have to raise my
daughter to learn how to protect
yourself and defend herself against the
world and what I've realized is that
it's actually possible and I believe it
with all my heart because of the work of
women like Tirana that we can hand our
daughters a different world and so I'm
full of like optimism tonight an
enthusiasm that we can make a change
it's gonna be permanent and lasting for
all of our children when did you hear
that you two would be able to walk the
carpet together and how did you how did
you two connector on the phone like way
longer and like way into the night and
and it started from it started from that
it started from her willingness to say
like yes that you know that we work in
different industries but that we can
really work together because that's
really the only way if we come together
and that really does mean all of us like
I find like I walked into my activism at
the Women's March in DC and since then I
have believed that we can make a
difference and then we can really make a
change but you know Tirana has been an
activist for the last 20 years but it's
possible for everyone at anytime to say
you know what I want to make something a
little bit better in it and I can be a
part of that you have changed the
conversation on this carpet we know what
the conversation is normally like that
we're talking dress as if but you've
changed the conversation though and that
changes the way the country filters what
happens here how important is that
what's exciting is that we felt as
disempowered as any group of female
workers and what you see reflected in
the stories that women have so bravely
come forward with about their
in our industry we felt frightened we
felt disempowered we felt like we really
didn't know how to stand up for
ourselves
and then we actually realized that this
was a place where we had a platform and
this is somewhere where if we had
something else that we wanted to talk
about other than our dresses we should
try and do that so tonight is our first
night and change I'm sure you know
better than I do it's a long process and
it's bumpy and it's ungainly actually
last thing what does this say to the
Harvey Weinstein's of the world you
being here tonight what does this say to
those men in power that are taking
advantage of their power